all right so this is the state of the
shiny website uh at the time of this
recording so it might be different uh by
the time people actually see this
but if you just start from this uh
this landing page for shiny for python
then you can click on examples and
there's a whole bunch of examples here
now uh and you can select them from the
sidebar so i'm just gonna go down wordle
is all the way down here in this
advanced section
and uh and here's our wordle app what's
your wordle starting word my word will
starter uh it's arise
can we can we play wordle i haven't
played words all right let me make this
a little bit bigger here all right so
are you still playing wordle every day i
am not you know i like i was
really hardcore for a while and then i
just
stopped and forgot one day and then i
forgot the next day and i just haven't
really
done very much of it since then all
right so yeah so my starters arise
just type that on my keyboard
did you just hit enter to make it do
that too yes i did so yeah and actually
i should i should point out that
that keyboard uh interaction
that is some
custom javascript that's added to this
app
because normally you know for a normal
web page if you just type in it it's not
going to send the key presses to
necessarily where you want to go
so there's a little bit of javascript
which
i'll walk through that that does that
it's pretty simple what's your strategy
do you go
i'm gonna keep
a-i-s in my next guess or are you like
nope i'm gonna go for full coverage i'm
going to pick something that excludes
those yeah you know i unless i think i
can get it the word in this next uh in
the next guess
i usually use another
not another word that will cover the
rest of the vowels so my next word that
i usually use is
pouty this is amazing you have a whole
strategy
all right so now i know there's no other
vowels
and
yeah there's t-a-i-n-s and so far
they've all been in the wrong spot yeah
so my guess would be that the s is last
that's common and
well that would be if s is last it would
almost be like blank a i t s
which
oh except for the t and the i can't be
in those locations keep coming up with
words that have the letter r which is
not helpful yeah
yeah and
steam stain
st
pretty good
that's good
thanks for jesse
[Laughter]
teamwork nice
pretty good three
yeah awesome and then it's got like a
nice little
you've got a little pop-up yeah you can
take this and you can copy and paste it
uh into twitter and then just really
confuse the heck out of everyone there
that's great yeah
now didn't you build this so that you
could play in as many guesses as you
wanted
yes that was
yeah sometimes i get a little lazy and i
just want to guess and not have to think
too hard about it and worry about
failing so yeah so this one doesn't it
doesn't stop you just keep guessing as
many times as you want i was thought
let's start with like the very minimal
thing that that you know like the
smallest simplest possible thing
um that we can build
and try to evolve that into into this
game here so that started out with just
you know having a simple text input and
letting people type in some stuff and
hit enter
and then from there it's like okay now
let's try to limit it let's limit that
to five characters let's actually add a
word list so that you know they're
guessing a particular word let's save
all their previous guesses
and then display them for the wordle app
i could sort of you know i could sort of
see a path from like this very simple
like let's start with just text input
and
let's try to turn it into
you know this full this full-fledged
game here
and that's something that i guess you
get from experience like you can see
like like okay i think it's possible to
get from you know from point a to point
b but sometimes it's not you can't just
start with something really really
simple and and evolve it into
something that looks nice and
sophisticated like this so sometimes you
do have to sit as well for me at least
sometimes i have to sit down and just
figure out like okay how am i what are
the going to be the big parts of this
and how are they going to fit together
how much python did you know
when you were doing this like when you
started this
um so when i started the wordle app i
think i've had you know i've been
programming i mean spending most of my
time in python well and also in
javascript for the last just about the
last year or so
but before that i barely used python at
all
yeah so uh yeah but i think by the time
when i started this app though
um when did i do this this is about four
months ago i think
i think it was longer was it i feel like
this was january february
oh you might be right yeah this might
have been one of the first things hey
guys
what
remember just be like at least the way
that i remember it the story that i'm
telling myself is that you were like
had a couple hours thought i'd do
something fun now portal like with
python in the browser and you can do
unlimited guesses yeah well i mean it
helped that there was you know we did we
already did the r1 first so
yeah so you so i mean just for context
how long have you been
writing our code i'm thinking i've had
though
doing serious r work i mean probably the
last i would say maybe 11 years doing
that yeah so that's that's that's a lot
of time to be a lot of time
working in our yeah yeah so i mean there
are there's a lot of there's a lot of
nice things about python
um
like i think it's like in terms of just
like the language itself it's it's um
it's designed to be
sort of to be easy to learn and
um it encourages sort of a clean coding
style
um there are some annoying limitations
if you come from a functional
programming language like r or
javascript you know you can't it doesn't
really support anonymous functions uh i
mean it does if they're if they're like
one
statement or one expression but um you
can't have a multi-line anonymous
expression which um
which means that you end up creating all
these functions that that you have to
give names to and then
and then you can before you can pass
them to stop to another function
and there's some there's some really
weird stuff uh and difficult stuff with
the tooling for for python like just not
in python itself but like all the stuff
around python like how to install
packages uh in you know and use them in
a reliable way how do you how do you
build a package there's like a zillion
ways to do things and that is that's
that's pretty difficult when i was first
you know looking into becoming a data
scientist i was going to learn python
and
it took me forever to get it installed
sometimes i couldn't get install but
then it was like you know pip install
whatever and i no one told you where to
put the command pip
and so i would put it in my browser yeah
yeah yeah
you run python and it launches python 2
on your computer instead of python 3 and
then none of the stuff you installed
with pip is there and it's like what why
isn't that working
so
yeah
it's a good time
bad stuff is not fun but actually that's
that's one reason that i'm really
excited about all this online editing
stuff that we've built
um
you know we have this editor here where
you can just get started running shiny
and um
all the stuff's already installed you
don't have to you don't have to install
python
um you don't have to install any
packages you don't i mean you don't even
have to run this on like a normal
computer you can run this on an ipad
where
you wouldn't even be able to install
python normally
so and and you know there's all you get
all this uh
all this assistance now like um
you know if i want to start from working
in this ui here
so i can say like
ui dot
you know input
under export
like check box
and and then it's got all this auto
completion stuff that's
right
this is new actually yeah this actually
wasn't this didn't exist in the last
video that we reported i this was just
implemented in the last couple of weeks
so
so yeah and then and you can hover over
it and there's oops that's a little bit
finicky but there's it gives you the
whole documentation right here
so that's that has been super helpful
that's really helpful for coding in the
browser and it also has all that support
for that for the python standard library
so you know i can say
from os import
path
and then i can say path dot
you know um base name
and then it it gives you all these these
hints here to to write the code so
that will hopefully
be a big help for for people to get
started and again and you don't have to
install the stuff in your computer and
get that all set up getting that you can
get that stuff set up um
like for example with vs code which i
often use for coding python and it's
it's it's really really nice but
there's you know that's more stuff you
have to set up then it's like okay you
got to set up ps code you got to install
the python
extensions you got to configure the
python extensions to give you that the
right sort of assistance and not you
know not and have it not flagged too
many things as errors so there's a lot
of work that can you know a lot of
manual work that would that would be
involved if you set it up on your own
system but
um if you don't want to do that you can
just come right in here and get working
right away i feel like we're cheating i
feel like
i feel like there's a catch like you're
gonna be like you can do all these cool
things like right there's no free lunch
i mean this isn't a theorem or anything
like that but
like if i want to learn shiny this feels
like such an approachable way to do it
yeah you know i mean you eventually
you'll probably if you're doing a lot of
shiny uh writing a lot of shiny code
eventually you'll probably hit
um hit some sort of road blocks if
you're if you just work this way
so um you know
in in developing this editor we've tried
to remove as many of those as possible
so you can
you know you can save these files to
your disk you can load them from disk
even though this is all running in your
web browser
um but when it comes to deploying your
application you're gonna have to get
into
the um
into the command line world
and and if you wanna do stuff that um
that you can't do in in this version of
shiny that's running completely in the
browser
with uh with python compiled to
webassembly so if you want to fetch data
from a database you don't want to share
those credentials
with the rest of the world or you just
you want to work on a data set or you
need you need a really powerful computer
to do some computation this isn't going
to really work for you like to to send
the code to the user's browser for them
to execute it um
that that might not work so
then you have to run it you know then
you have to run it the traditional way
which is with python running on the
server and you're gonna have to get your
hands dirty with you know installing
python and configuring it and all that
sort of stuff there i'm gonna say it's
not too bad vs code does it for me and
it just works and so i
have not touched it
that's true that's true
visual studio too visual studio did my c
sharp my python and it just works and i
was like you know visual studio we're
just not going to touch anything else
yeah this is all on python but you've
also mentioned some css and some
javascript okay yeah let's talk about
this so i'm going to actually switch
over to another tab where i have it
running the same thing running locally
because i've actually made some changes
um one of the things that i talked about
was uh this javascript to deal with the
key the key presses so this keyboard
here these are all action buttons
and you know when you click on them it
sets a a value that the server function
can read so this is you know obviously
that's the button p there
and i can hit backspace
now
in order to trigger these with the
keyboard i had to set up a little bit of
extra stuff and that's it's relatively
simple so
uh at least as this javascript code goes
so basically i set up
in javascript an array of all these
letters and then i add an event listener
for a key down event all right so this
is just a javascript so when the button
is pressed then it grabs
uh it gets the element by id so like the
elements i created these buttons with
ids you know a b c d and so on and then
it triggers a click on them
and then there's special handling for
the enter and back buttons
but um but yeah that's basically it is i
just i'm just basically like when
somebody presses the keyboard it
triggers a click on the action button
and so the and the rest of it is just
sort of normal shiny behavior okay so um
and you know if you're not
familiar with javascript but you still
want to do this it's really easy you
just copy paste this code that's
i'm copying and pasting your code what
am i
just putting it inside tags.script oh
yeah yes
right so uh yes so i have
tags.script
here actually and let me let me
explain that a little bit so tags is
actually something that was
i imported from
the html tools package
and that that is something that has all
of the html tag functions so you know
like div span
um script in this case
now you can do it that way importing it
from html tools or
um another place that it's available is
also via the ui object
in shiny so i can say ui.tags
actually delete all this so let's start
over so you can say ui.tags
dot
and then these are these are all of the
um
available html tags so
so
yeah so the one that i want though is
script
closing parenthesis
and there we are so yeah so let's put it
in a script tag in html
and then the browser notes that
it's javascript that's really cool and
then it's just all within your broader
ui
yep so that's just that's just you know
anywhere um
in
in the ui for the app um
you can put you can put it there and
then the browser will just execute that
javascript
code
that's really cool
yeah it's it's it's pretty easy to add
the javascript
so when you're adding it oh this is all
looks like it's in a doc string
but it's still yeah
well as it's not exactly a dot string
it's um
it's a triple quote string
actually you know what i might i could
be getting my terminology wrong for
python so you
for doc strings you usually write them
with you know triple quotes but uh it
just means that you know with the triple
quotes i can use multiple lines um the
string can span multiple lines
but but it's like i mean this would be a
traditional way of like commenting
something out but you're saying because
it's in the triple quotes it's still
reading this javascript
yeah well i mean it's yeah it is it's
well because it's in the triple quotes
it's just it treats it just as a string
but i can still use you know i can the
string can span multiple lines and i can
use quotes in it without
you know making it confused that it's
the end of the string
um unless i put three in a row to to
shiny this is just this is just text
and it happens to be i happen to be
sticking it in the script tag
um and so then you know actually if i do
you can do it here
um
[Music]
yeah so then
shiny is just like okay i'm going to put
the string in a script tag and that's
going to be that's going to be in the
web page like right here now there's
actually a file in in in this app called
style.css
and
um what i'm doing here is i'm actually
just reading in this files text
and returning it and that's and then
it's sticking it in
in the app as a string so that's you
know so i have this is the styling the
css stuff for for this world app
um
and this is in this case instead of
instead of putting it in line like i did
with the javascript i i read it in from
the file
so that's another way of doing something
that's similar and actually the nice
thing about that then is that this
editor understands css and so it gives
me some syntax highlighting and
i think it'll tell me if they've got
well maybe not
i thought it would tell me if there's
problems with it
but uh it apparently does not but it
does have syntax highlighting and you
know if you use another editor it might
be smart enough to
to give you
that sort of help so i could have i
could have put the javascript code in
the same way so you know create a new
file with the javascript and then just
insert it
similar to this there's multiple files
in this app and um one of them was the
css file another another one is this
words dot
pi file so
all the words are defined in this this
python file
okay and you can just sort of import
that the way you normally would from
uh in a python script so you'd say
import words and and also once again you
know most of these html tools objects
are actually
available via ui so via the shiny ui so
the shiny dot ui module actually imports
html tools
and then it exports most of those things
so i think actually for this i
technically didn't have to import them
from html tools directly
some of this javascript code here um
like this stuff here this was all touch
interaction like on your phone or ipad
because that's that's often how i play
portal and
with the normal wordle app or the real
word lab i should say i find it a little
annoying like you you touch the letter
and it doesn't register until you let go
of your you raise your finger off the
letter
so that that leg kind of bothers me um
and
so i added
these other event listeners so that if
when you touch the letter
it immediately uh registers it so you
don't have to you know touch and then
release
so that's uh that's what this stuff does
here i'm really impatient for this ui
interaction stuff so
that's i love this is i don't want to
say it's like spite driven development
but it's like a little thing
that you know how to improve so you like
make your own version of it i love it
yeah so here's another thing that's
unusual about this app
that we haven't done in any of the other
examples
and it's to uh create
actually a subclass of inputs um where
we specify the type of these various uh
well the various inputs so so this is so
this was a shiny nose like hey when
somebody presses the enter button like
what what kind of value is going to come
out of that so we say you know class
shiny inputs and this is makes it a
subclass of inputs and i just declare
all these things here the enter button
and the back button those return
integer values
um as does the new game button and so
that's so you know like hey this doesn't
return a string or a boolean
it returns it returns a number right so
inside of the server app first i just
say hey take the input object and cast
it to shiny inputs just treat it as
shiny inputs okay then i can say
oops i can say output
render text
and def
my function here oh wait now you can
keep the name called
txt
and if i say return
input dot enter
it's going to say hey there's something
wrong here
um
this error message is kind of long and
cryptic
but the important part is
function return type inch is
incompatible with the weightable string
or not so it's complaining about this
this returns a number but this render
text wants a function that returns a
string so i can you know what i would
have to do is convert that to a string
now it turns out that if you you know if
you hand the number to render text it
will it'll handle it'll try to convert
it to a string anyway but there's other
weird objects that you might give to it
that um have the wrong shape like
uh if you return you know a dictionary
to it or if you return to some sort of
arbitrary weird python object you might
not know how to handle it
so so having these uh
declaring the types
of these inputs and having it check them
is uh is really helpful well if you if
you are like really strict about things
so if i say like hey i've got
x um
an x is a dictionary of uh or sorry it's
a list of strings
um
i can't say
you know assign this boolean value to
that list of strings well for two
reasons one is that it's boolean the
other one is that it's you know
it's not a list
uh so it's not a list and it's not a
string
um but like maybe maybe i said hey x is
a list of strings we'll call it i'll
assign it you know this empty brackets
first um and then i could say x dot
um append
you know input.heart that's like hey no
this is a boolean this is not a string
you got you've still got an error so
then i can say oh you know what that's
right i actually need to convert this to
a string first
or maybe i want to say like hey
you know like
yes
if it's input.hard else no
so
this is this expression is going to
return either yes or no depending on the
value of
yeah
but
um
but yeah so having these types can help
you know help you avoid bugs in your
code by
with
in combination with a smart editor like
this that will you know that will flag
these type errors oh yeah actually yeah
one thing that i wanted to talk about
was the this use of reactive values here
reactive data value
so
there's a bunch of these here um
one of them is that the target word uh
one of them is like all of the guesses
that that the user has made in this
round whether the game has ended
and what are the current
guess the current letters in the guest
so you know if i type a r i um those
letters are the the letters in the
current guest you don't see this for
really basic shiny apps you don't see
this reactive.value
stuff
uh let me pull up a really simple
example here so like let's go to this
basic app here
so this basic app you just have an input
right input.n and then that gets used by
this output
so
for an app like this
if i set the state of an input
that will be consumed by the output and
um
and that's that so there's no there's no
recording of of history like what like
what was the previous state of an input
that just doesn't isn't part of this
application that's just totally you know
it's just totally gone um and that's
that's what happens if you just have
inputs just that are used by outputs but
nothing to record the previous states
so
here i'm using reactive values to um
record the history so the history in
this case was that i pressed ari and
then you know i can fill that out s e if
i hit enter
then
you know then
arise will be recorded in
uh all guesses so when you see these
reactive values that's often what you
what it's used for is to to help record
some previous statement okay that's
important for that's important for many
you know more sophisticated applications
all right so another unusual feature
about this app is so i'm i'm creating
reactive effects
um that respond to each key press
but i'm doing that in a loop
so that is a little bit unusual
so let's see here so uh there's i
created a list called keys that's um
where is it
it's up here so this is all the the
letters in the keyboard
or all the ones that we want to use
and
so i had all those uh
all these action buttons here right this
one's named q w
e r you know those are all individual
action buttons
and
i want
uh i want this application
to
uh update the current
guest letters
uh whenever one of those buttons is
pressed
now one way to do that is i could create
a reactive effect for each every single
one so you know i could do oops let's
not put it there
down here i could say
um
uh sorry reactive
dot effect
uh
reactive dot
event
and this would listen to
you know input dot
q
i think it's capitalized
and then i'd say def underscore and then
and then in here i would say okay when
the cue button is pressed um take the
current
guest letters and
oh actually
this is a little bit complicated
oops train guest letters
invoke that as function copy it
i'll just call this x
x dot append
you know
cube
and then
current guest letters letters.set
x all right so there's actually a few
things going on here um i should this is
actually an important enough
digression that i'm gonna do it right
now
um
current guest letters is
it's a it will return a list
and you see that i'm copying this list
modifying it and then setting uh current
guest letters to that new list
instead of just taking that list and
modifying it
so the reason for that is
because
this is a reactive value and in order
for
it to sort of inform everyone that
consumes like all the things that use
that reactive value
um
they need they need to know like hey
the value here has changed
uh in order for them to invalidate and
to know that they have to recompute
now if i just change if i were to just
take this and then append q to it
and not do this copying and setting
stuff uh
then i would modify that list
but i wouldn't i wouldn't be informing
everyone that it had been updated so um
and also it could confuse some of the
other uh some other code like if i just
modify that object in place so that's
actually one important difference
between python and r is that in our most
of these things most objects are
immutable
um and so you you actually can't
cause this sort of problem
but in python you have to be you have to
be sort of aware of you know what
what objects can be changed in place and
how that can
um that can cause problems with this
reactive computation now i don't think
that
you know shiny's uniqueness in this
respect like i know if you're working
with like pandas data frames the same
thing uh can also happen but it is one
more thing to be aware of uh compared to
the r version of shiny we would have to
do this for
like
every single key on our keyboard right
uh i would have i so i did this for the
letter q you know i'd do it for the
letter w and
and e
r t all of those
but that's obviously you know that's
really tedious no take up a bunch of
space and then if i found out that
there's a bug in my code i'd have to
change
all of them which is a huge pain so
instead of doing it this way
what i did was i created a
so there's a function make key listener
which
creates
this reactive effect that listens for a
specific key
so it can take the name of the key so uh
you know the first one would be q
and it's a you know reactive event it's
listening for input bracket key that's
this is actually equivalent to
so
like i could do input dot q here or i
can do input
bracket queue those actually both work
those are equivalent
um
you know the dot
syntax is a little bit more convenient
if you're just typing it out for a
single thing but if you need to
programmatically
access an input value you can uh you can
do it this way in the in the bracket
so i'm saying you know listen for
whatever key you know i was told to
listen to and then do all that same
stuff that we just saw except the key
here is you know instead of hard coding
cue it's it's
it's comes in from this function call
okay so if i call this function i can
pass up the letter q and the letter w
and e and so on
um and that's what i'm doing here i have
a for loop that uh creates the key
listener for all of those keys
and again there's exceptions for
entering back buttons because those are
handled separately those have different
behavior from their other keys
but yeah but essentially it just it
calls us in a loop now
you might be thinking like hey
can i just
instead of making this function here
can i put
just copy this code and just stick it
right down here
right if i could say hey let's you know
forget putting it on this function i'll
just put it right there and properly
indent it
um
so you if you do this though it's not
going to work
the the problem is that
it has to do with how it captures the
value of key actually i'll just put it
here first so we can take a look
so
what this is going to do it's going to
go it's going to iterate all over all of
the keys i've got this inner for loop
this variable key
will change every time um every time it
goes through the loop what ends up
happening is it does create a separate
reactive effect
for each one of those keys but
um this value of key is shared across
all of them and it actually keeps
changing so
let me maybe it's best for if i just
demonstrate so let me just run this app
here all right so i've i've changed it
so that instead of calling this make key
listener function it's actually creating
those effects from this loop here
and if i press uh the button
i hope this is actually gonna work
it
did something crazy wow that is not what
i expected oh
i did okay this this is actually the
same problem
right this is actually the prime i was
talking about it just it just ended up
somewhere where i didn't expect so
right so here's let's see all the
letters are
up here right so it just iterates over
them in this order so you know it goes
from q
w
all the way and then the last one is
back
so the letter the value of key actually
kept
changing as it iterated over this and
um
the scope for this variable is like
it's
scoped to the server function this key
variable it's not saving
the value of key for each time we called
this loop the this this variable key
here is actually like at the top level
of the server function
and it kept changing as we're going
through the loop
um
when we call it in this function here
um instead of
that key
keep constantly changing you know
actually i can just i can rename this to
something a little bit i'll just call
this k to make it clearer
um
like this letter k here this variable k
is just scoped within this function so
when i was saying hey
make you know
make a keyboard snare of key
and then you know ignore that stuff down
there
um
it passed in the letter q and then
it created this reactive effect and
reactive event
um and the variable k
was have the value of q and it that was
captured within the scope of this uh
within the scope of this closure
okay that's that's the terminology
and and then they created a separate one
a separate closure scope for w and for e
and so that variable k is not sort of
shared across all of those instances
so that that's that's that's what
happened here as opposed to you know
what we have uh
in this messed up version where the
variable value of key was shared across
all of them and so did something really
bizarre
so um i hope that made sense i thought
as soon as you said closure i was like
i hear jenny
yeah
okay
let jenny be your guide
yeah always literally
yeah so that's um that's most of the
weird stuff that is in this application
um there is some css i won't get too
into depth about that that's a whole
you know that's nothing
specific to shiny about this this is
just like web development stuff which
um
i i'm also like i'm okay with css i'm
not great with css i wouldn't be the
person to explain it and a lot of this
a lot of the css to lay this out was
just sort of like trial and error and me
hacking away at it and um
until i got something that looked
decent
i feel like you know not the css person
myself but i feel like that's the right
way to do this
uh in sort of like the tree of
complexity of for your application this
is just sort of like a leaf node it's
just okay just make this work it's not
gonna mess up anything else all right so
yeah that's fertile